plus de 22 000 morts c'est le dernier
bilan du tremblement de terre qui a
secoué lundi le sud de la Turquie et la
Syrie une tragédie qui prive également
de toi des centaines de milliers
d'habitants pour venir en aide à ces
familles qui ont tout perdu l'Union des
femmes turques de Touraine recueille des
dons en argent avec un certain succès
vous allez le voir dans ce reportage à
la riche de Romain Delville
pour récolter des fonds après le séisme
qui a frappé la Turquie et la Syrie
Sylvie Haliti et sur tous les fronts la
présidente de l'Union des femmes turques
de Touraine récoltent des dons avec son
équipe dans le hall de la mairie de la
riche avec une poignée de bénévoles de
l'association des dons financiers mais
pas matériels en raison de l'urgence et
de la logistique difficile à mettre en
place l'organisation surface est
beaucoup plus efficace que si nous on
collectés ont trié on a envoyé d'ici
arrivé là-bas déjà on perdrait
énormément de temps et c'est pour ça
qu'on collecte pas de vêtements ou de ou
dedans réalimentaire et qu'on se
contente de collecter des fonds pour
justement aider les organisations qui
sont sur place Magic chelgaff est une
figure locale de l'entraide et du monde
associatif un pas vers l'autre une des
associations qu'il préside a pour but de
faire les courses pour les personnes
isolées cet après-midi au nom de
l'assaut il a apporté un chèque de 300
euros
et aussi valable pour les autres des
autres situations et là en l’occurrence
c'est une situation très très compliquée
il faut pas avoir de cœur pour ne pas
penser à ces gens-là beaucoup de
donateurs et donatrices individuelles
préfèrent rester discret par respect
envers les victimes du séisme de
l'indice dont le bilan provisoire
s'élève à plus de 22 000 morts